le projet d'évacuation nocturne des
casques blancs était risqué la ville de
dera était presque complètement encerclé
les bombardements de l'armée syrienne
avaient commencé un millier de personnes
considérées comme des terroristes par le
régime al-assad devait être secourus
c'était à la fin de juillet dernier
seulement 400 22 d'entre elles soit une
centaine de casques blancs et leurs
familles seront finalement évacué vers
israël puis transférés en jordanie
on ne connaît pas le sort de ceux qui
sont restés l'opération a été menée à
l'initiative du canada avec le
royaume-uni l'allemagne et les états
unis
ça a été très difficile de quitter mais
sur la masse fille et son mari faisait
partie du groupe
elle a pleuré pendant tout le trajet
cette nuit là puisqu'elle a bordeaux
n'est sa famille et une partie ses amis
et collègues casques blancs consciente
qu'elle ne les reverrai sans doute
jamais
après avoir passé trois mois dans un
camp en jordanie le couple vit depuis
peu à hamilton en ontario
moi je ne suis pas remise de tout ça je
vais toujours des cauchemars
la vie est très calme ici mais je
sursaute encore au moindre bruit de
klaxon nos pensées et nos âmes sont
toujours là bas mais sonne al masri
travaillait comme journaliste pour
l'agencé syrienne officielle sana
quand les bombardements de l'armée ont
commencé au début des manifestations en
elle a progressivement pris ses
distances ses patrons lui interdisait de
parler des arrestations arbitraires des
violations des droits de la personne des
attaques meurtrières
puis un jour son frère et son neveu ont
été tués visés par des tireurs d'élite
de l'armée
elle était tout près mais n'a pas pu
intervenir
on n'est qu'à mon canot canada martin
nous nous battons je me sentais inutile
incapable de lui sauver la vie c'est une
des principales raisons qui m'ont incité
à me joindre aux casques blancs de ma
ville
mais son al masri raconte que les
snipers de l'armée postés dans les
étages supérieurs des immeubles de la
ville
s'amusait à tirer sur les habitants les
enfants les bébés dans les bras de leur
mère mais ça n'a participé aux
expéditions de secours aux côtés des
hommes pour venir en aide en particulier
aux femmes et aux enfants blessés
chaque il contourne c'était parfois
dangereux de se rendre sur les lieux
d'un bombardement
parce que le régime savais que nous
allions arriver et il en profitait pour
nous attaquer aussi parfois il fallait
s'abstenir ou attendre avant d'aller
secourir les blessés
le régime de bachar el assad et la
russie accuse les casques blancs de
prendre part au combat aux côtés des
rebelles
mais sonne al masri répondre que les
casques blancs ne sont pas tous des
anges que si certains l'ont fait il
n'aurait pas dû
puisque leur seule mission est de sauver
des
nous sommes aussi allés porter secours
dans les quartiers pro assad
nous avons même soigné des soldats
syriens on n'a jamais demandé aux
blessés de quel côté ils étaient avant
de leur venir en aide
[Musique]
le gouvernement canadien considère que
les casques blancs serieys sont de
véritables héros avec le royaume uni
l'allemagne la france et d'autres pays
le canada à financer les activités du
groupe humanitaire à hauteur de
plusieurs millions de dollars par année
aujourd'hui on ne sait pas combien sont
encore en vie plusieurs ont été faits
prisonniers
ils sont détenus dans les geôles du
régime dictatorial ceux et celles qui
ont eu la chance de fuir le pays attend
sont maintenant disséminés dans les pays
qui ont contribué à leur évasion
au canada les familles de casques blancs
continuent d'arriver
ils seront bientôt plus d'une centaine
répartis à travers le pays phare
al-madani mode fr ou à la même taille et
alors qu'arnaud chaque maintenant nous
les casques blancs nous sommes toujours
prêts à servir et à aider c'est devenu
un mode de vie nous espérons pouvoir
continuer à agir de la même manière nous
aimerions contribuer à sauver des vies
ici aussi si c'est possible
mais ce n'est son mari tiennent à
remercier les canadiens pour leur
accueil qu'il qualifie de chaleureux
dans leur nouveau quartier d'adoption
quand il regarde vers le ciel ce ne sont
plus les avions de l'armée et leurs
bombes qu'ils voient